[Music]
science those science people have
discovered that there's a liquid water
under the icy surface of Europa which is
one of Jupiter's largest moons Europa
meaning life could exist on another
planet not like full upright aliens
walking around talking about what to
probe not like that but like exciting
real life like little little little
squids and microbes and the me like
amoebas that could turn into they could
mult
who gives a [__] I can feel all of you
not giving a [__] I stopped giving a
[__] and I was the one saying it that's
how boring that was no one cares and you
know what that's actually my point space
listen to me space that stuff that's all
around us
is the most fascinating boring thing in
the world it's fascinating and boring at
the exact same time we don't care we
don't care about space we know we should
but we don't because it's boring we know
I know I know there's an infinite
universe right above our heads expanding
forever filled with impossible realities
but down here there's food
[Applause]
right Isis got anything to eat
what's that spice no no spice then suck
it space we don't care we don't care
that stars or huge balls you try and
read a card that says huge balls and not
have a little moment to yourself we
don't care that star they're huge balls
of ice huge balls of energy millions of
miles away collapsing into black holes
that could lead to other dimensions some
of you laughed at black holes and I like
that I like that a lot that's next-level
[__] right there these black holes
though the real ones could be the very
answers to our own puzzling existence we
want art wings no hot wings no deal
you can have your hydrogen and your
carbon and mix them together blah blah
degrees Kelvin I'll take some blue
cheese mixed with ranch thank you very
much it's Kara we only care about things
you can and things you can eat on this
planet I mean we had to start the rumor
that the moon was made of cheese just to
get the American people interested
that's how much nobody gave a [__] about
the moon we're going to the moon who
cares
made of cheese
government funding approved take this
flag in these delicious town house
crackers there's a delicious buttery
taste baked right in but think about it
Mars Mars that's a great thing the Milky
Way those are amazing things right but
as soon as you figure out someone means
the planet and the solar system not the
nougaty delicious candy bars everybody's
eyes just glaze over even just then I've
been talking about the wonder of space
for a while now but for a lot of you the
word glaze has been your favorite part
of this monologue just sitting there
like chocolate glazed strawberry glaze
regular glaze glaze
how are you smoking love a good glaze
and I know some of you were watching
like at home like hey I love space I
love space Star Wars Independence Day
Star Wars - critic critic - don't space
those are movies about space those are
just movies about kicking the [__] out
of people who happened to be in space
you want to know what a real space movie
is contact yeah that Jodie Foster movie
from the 90s okay but I can feel the
majority of you thinking contact sucked
and it did contact sucked you know why
cuz it was actually about space
[Applause]
[Music]